ja das ist das schöne an finden wir
respektieren uns wir entschuldigen uns
muss man am tag kosten
aber das thema was jetzt kommt auch
ehrlicherweise was mit entschuldigen zu
tun und auch etwas mit respekt zu tun
aber auch damit die freiheit zu haben
seine meinung zu sagen es gibt das
schöne zitat die freiheit stirbt
zentimeterweise deshalb ich mir heute
mittag notierte stammt nicht von mir
sondern von dem 1973 verstorbenen
politiker karl hermann flach das zitat
wirkt jedoch aktueller denn je weil ich
kann diese zeit nicht oft genug
wiederholen unter 50 prozent der
deutschen haben nicht mehr das gefühl
ihre politische meinung sagen zu können
natürlich nicht weil wir keine
meinungsfreiheit haben die es im
grundgesetz verankert jeder kann seine
meinung sagen das machen wir jetzt
beispiel jeden abend in anderen ländern
dürfte ich mich gar nicht so äußern wie
es hier immer bei bild mache aber die
menschen spüren diese meinungsfreiheit
nicht mehr und dadurch ist sie in gefahr
und das schlimmste daran ist dass
menschen auch gesellschaftliche
repressalien bekommt wenn sie ihre
meinung sagen und dass es gefährlich ist
war vor drei wochen jemand im gästeraum
ein gast der aufladung später bei film
nach 8 satz nicht voll
entschuldige bitte aber ich werde heute
nicht so stark meine meinung sagen nach
dem letzten mal habe ich zur aufträge
verloren das stört mich zwar nicht weil
ich erfolgreich bin aber trotzdem ich
will mich ein bisschen zurückhaltend das
hat mir angst gemacht wenn schon
persönlichkeiten des öffentlichen lebens
sich nicht mehr trauen ihre meinung zu
sagen aus angst vor repressalien doch
heute hatte ich hoffnung und zwar wegen
der aktion der schauspieler und
wissenschaftler die heißt alles auf den
tisch es gab schon mal die aktion alles
dicht machen vielleicht erinnern sie
sich mit jan josef liefers wo auch
volker buch dabei war den wir hier sehen
die wurde fertig gemacht die
schauspieler als würde das fordert dass
jan josef liefers seinen job verliert
volker bruch ebenso bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen sendern volker bruch und
wurde an wilke möhring beide haben auch
schon mal alles dichtmachen mitgemacht
haben sie jetzt wieder gemacht werden
ihre meinung gesagt bzw im interviews
geführt mit wissenschaftlern mit einer
nötig an und haben über themen geredet
die diese videos haben sie online
gestellt und das ist heute passiert sie
wollten eigentlich nur mal andere
meinungen er hörbar machen andere corona
prognose und sie wurden wieder gefedert
und geträufelt auf twitter und co
dementsprechend möchte ich mich heute
bei ihnen bedanken es ist nicht der sich
über zustimmen es ist auch nicht also
jedes video großartig gelungen finde ich
bin zum beispiel auch volker buch hätte
die fragen ein bisschen besser stellen
können aber ich bin dankbar dass sie es
getan haben denn widerspruch ist in
einer demokratie das lebenselexier
ja da bin ich ganz deiner meinung und
mir macht es auch tatsächlich angst was
du gerade gesagt hast dass wir unsere
meinung oder und schon überlegen können
wir das überhaupt doch sagen und da geht
es gar nicht nur um politische themen da
geht es ja auch um themen die du einfach
in deinem umfeld du hast eine meinung
dazu und es ist mittlerweile so in
unserer gesellschaft es gibt nur noch
schwarz oder weiß es gibt keine
zwischentöne mehr und es ist auch nur
noch so die fronten sind von vornherein
verhärtet ich habe meine meinung ich
sehe das so du siehst das anders das
finde ich total daneben und dann habe
schon wieso die leute haben es verlernt
einfach mal erst mal zuzuhören so okay
das ist ein argument warum kann ich das
verstehen warum kann ich das nicht
verstehen was macht das mit mir wie es
mein argument jeder hat ja nur seine
eigene wahrheit die die reine wahrheit
gibt es in dem sinne gar nicht weil
jeder sie anders interpretiert und ich
finde wir müssen mal dahin zurückkommen
dass wir einander anhören und dass wir
einander hinterfragen und einfach auch
mal versuchen einen gemeinsamen weg zu
finden weil am ende stecken wir in
dieser pandemie oder auch in der ganzen
klimakrise wir stecken überall zusammen
drin und wir sollten das doch
wertschätzen dass der eine vielleicht
kleinere schritte macht als der andere
aber macht schritte und das ist toll und
da sollten wir uns darauf konzentriert
auf das positive und da vorangehen ich
glaube dass das problem in wirklichkeit
ein anderes ist und habe einige dieser
leute eben gesehen und ich glaube nicht
dass diese leute also die da sich heute
ausgedrückt haben das deren problem
damit haben dass sie ihre meinung nicht
sagen können denn die hat ja nicht
gesagt doch ich glaube die haben ein
anderes problem die haben das problem
dass sie halt tatsächlich ihre meinung
sagen aber niemand hört zu und das
problem ist dass tatsächlich das was man
dort hört den anderen habe ich ja
gesehen auch nicht wirklich so super
interessant ist
wichtiger unterschied ja die leute sind
frustriert dass sie mit ihrer magen zu
der sie so stehen und wovon sie so
überzeugen dass sie mit dieser mahnung
die korona politik in deutschland nicht
bestimmen kann ich solle mir wichtiger
punkt lena wahl ist ja noch das gefühl
ist das gefühl dass mit aufzunehmen das
gerade am beginn der kroner pandemie
eben nur bestimmte experten eingeladen
wurden das bestätigte meinung nicht
vorgekommen ich möchte gerade
und ich hab das vorbereiten ich wusste
dass ich habe es im gespür gehabt und
ich freue mich jetzt sehr über meine
vorbereitung und zwar ich habe die
ganzen videos also die ich habe auch
schon mal wie man videos geguckt und ein
video fand ich spannend vor allem viele
anrufe von volker bruch ich sag ihnen
nur die these und sie sagen ob sie es
spannend von ups ist unspannend man
braucht als öffentlich rechtlicher
rundfunk einen faktencheck das ist im
journalismus mit eingebaut spannend oder
nicht die these
finde ich nicht so spannend war das
ehrlich wir machen den faktencheck total
die zeiten sehen was nicht rechtlichen
rundfunk also wenn ich in so eine
sendung eingehen es gibt also zumal
einige sendungen haben den etabliert in
dem sinn dass einige fakten check die
entweder korrekten vor der tagesschau
faktencheck als geht um die etablierten
faktencheck die these besprochen wurde
und das fand ich schon spannend warum
braucht man überhaupt beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen sender einen
faktencheck vor allem und die these war
auch spannend es wäre so dass ihr auch
jeder fakt von anderen seiten gesehen
wird und das ist ja auch bei kone müssen
sie auch seien bei vielen sachen ja auch
standpunkt weise auch verschieden und
ich kann total spannend wie erklärt
wurde der faktencheck wird angezweifelt
wir auch der faktencheck native
weltsichten innerhalb beim öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk zum beispiel was
ich also ich glaube ich einfach schlicht
nicht also zunächst mal muss man
unterscheiden zwischen also der
regierungspolitik und dem was den
öffentlich-rechtlichen diskutiert wird
es gar nicht nur das nicht reichen jahr
genau von na ja und ich finde da
tatsächlich das ist meine persönliche
meinung das mag ihr unpopulär sein aber
sage ich als einfach mal nicht
meine meinung ist dass sagen mal in der
berichterstattung
also und auch in also zum beispiel in
den talkshows aber auch in der qualität
online medien dass wir in deutschland
eine sehr hohe qualität des journalismus
gehabt haben finde ich einfach im
vergleich zu einer ländern ich habe
jetzt sagen wir das privileg das sehr
gut mit den vereinigten staaten
vergleichen kann und
die qual dass ich halt leider sehr viel
lesen muss in der kroner politik auch
aus anderen europäischen ländern was man
dort ließ ist zum teil also hsk es muss
uns sagen und wir hatten noch keine
qualität und was wir nicht gemacht haben
ist was ich auch für fans gefunden hatte
wir haben es manchmal gemacht aber es
ist wenn wir es gemacht haben war wir
haben also
wissenschaftler die nicht so super stark
impfstoff sind oder andere schwerpunkte
haben die haben wir nicht
gleichberechtigt gehört mit den leuten
die quasi also sehr nah am stoff sind
und das ist auseinander sich auch
richtig ich möchte vielleicht vielleicht
berechneten haben gleichberechtigt
[Musik]